I want to take the phone call of a good
friend of the program and a good friend
in general he's a three-time NBA
champion won the the he was part of the
first three-peat of the Chicago Bulls
and every single Monday we plan on
having a guest on from that era to talk
about the two episodes of the last
stance that will be airing the night
before and our first guest is BJ
Armstrong how are you BJ you know hope
you were doing well thanks again for
having me on the floor Susie wanted to
send her best my wife food loves
everybody loves BJ Armstrong so on here
did you learn anything new last night BJ
watching the first two you know you know
I was with my wife last night it's
always weird I've always thought
uncomfortable watching myself on
television right like a old game would
come on and I'll just walk out of the
room this is really weird to watch
because you know you you knew the
stories and to watch it and know who
were what's coming up next it's a it's
kind of it's kind of weird to watch
right it's kind of eerie a little bit
and but it was fun right to revisit
because you're seeing the reaction of so
many people who didn't know these
stories and especially the youth today
so you know it's been interesting to
watch the reactions well obviously again
you were not part of the last dance as a
matter of fact I mean in in what by that
I mean the final three-peat of the Bulls
but you were we did see we did catch you
last night hug and Michael after a
warrior's game cuz you were on the
Warriors at the time we did he did kind
of spot you doing that last night but I
guess I'll just start here with this
question that a lot of people are gonna
have throughout the ten episodes why did
this team get broken up why
BJ well you know you know rich when you
play sports you and you play and you win
you know one of the things that I think
you always have known and what I learned
very quickly when I came in this league
is rich
in it always ends bad always and I
learned that watching the Pistons when
the Pistons run ended it ended back when
the Lakers living out here in LA now
when the Lakers run ended with Shaq and
Kobe it just ended bad and you know you
can look now at the Patriots you know
what with Brady when it ends it always
ends bad it's never a right time it's
never a long time but you know what's
gonna end so I think it was Pat Riley or
someone's you know said it best you know
the ego the me is going to end every
it's going to end every right and it's
just a matter when it's going to happen
not if it's going to happen and that's
just human got humans
that's human behavior and it's human
behavior at its highest moment and you
know watching the Bulls know I learned
you know on the job you know that the
greatest opponent the greatest opponent
that I faced in sports was success in
failure
how are you going to deal with it and
what you're seeing here you know the
first two episodes anyways you see you
know how challenging it is to not do it
just individually but collectively as a
group so that you can continue to get to
the end result right and the end results
in sports is winning and automated
winning the championship so you know
that's just the way it is that's a part
of the game that's why you know I found
the challenging is how could you get
these other 11 people and get us all on
the same page where something was going
to unite us and find us a way to live
outside of ourselves it's it seemed yeah
of course and it seemed to me last night
seeing how Jordan chafed at a minutes
restriction in his second year chafed
coming off the floor with seconds to go
cuz he had hit his minutes restriction
that that was something that soured him
on Bulls management and it never changed
did you see that when you first arrived
in Chicago well you know rich oh you
know that was one of the eye-opening
experiences that I experienced if I can
just you know just share that
when I came into the league you know I
was I was happy-go-lucky kid right I was
living out my dream um but what I
quickly found out that it was a job and
more for me it was a business and I
struggled with that when I first came in
the NBA because I was like well someone
forgot to tell me that this was a
business right if I didn't make this
shot here they were gonna find someone
and get someone who could make that shot
it was you know it just is what it is
and I think Michaels understanding of
the business I mean he saw it firsthand
and I think that had a great impression
and every player that plays professional
sports they come up they're faced with
that because we think of sports you know
we have such fond memories and sports
and competition and winning and
sportsmanship and all of those things
and you suddenly find out that
professional sports is a business and
it's a business through and through you
can't deny it and you got to figure out
how to do with it in mine my way to deal
with this was I made a commitment I
could when I was young player like in my
first and second year I said look I'm
here I got a job to do but I'm gonna I'm
not gonna allow anyone or anyone in the
organization or anyone in this league
steal my joy because I I wanted to
always remember what it felt like and
what I dreamed about doing which was
playing in the NBA someday so um that
was tough to watch because every player
goes to that and you saw Michael go
through it and look at face to face and
I just think that was his moment to
understand of what he was really into
right he was a basketball player but he
also understood the business to such a
degree that I think allowed him to
achieve success beyond anyone's wildest
imagination because at the time no one
wasn't building teams around a six six
to guard and that was a challenge in and
of itself well in in terms of the animus
towards management I mean we're seeing
in the last dances it was playing out
that they didn't hide it I mean they
would just bark at Jerry Krause or make
fun of them or in the case of Pippen
barking at him or or Jordan just openly
mocking him
what was that the case when you got
there did you learn that Jerry Krause
was not to be liked or did you have your
own relationship with him what was that
like what the one thing is you know
sports is very interesting because you
you know you you're playing this game
and you're playing the game and it's
heightened emotions so you know III I
saw it I saw the the back-and-forth I
saw all of those things but again I had
to be incredibly professional and never
get caught up into anything that was
going to allow me not to do my job yes
did that happen I think you saw a little
bit of it with last night with Scotty
Michael and those guys and that was a
part of the culture that we had there um
but the key thing was is that as a group
as a team we never allow what was going
on off the court to affect what was
going on on the court there wasn't
anything that was said about not to like
this guy to like this guy everyone
understood that at any moment you know
let's just be let's just be very
transparent here and any morning anyone
could have gotten traded people could
have got moves what have you you know we
don't listen
that series against the Pistons maybe
the whole team is rebound who knows but
the key is is that you know what that's
that that's that's part of it right and
and I learned on the job that I had to
be comfortable being uncomfortable so
playing in chaos playing with all these
things rolling around that was everyday
normal occurrence for me I learned how
to deal with it and I learned how to
perform whatever was going on and just
block it out so I had the attitude rich
whatever that was like my work whatever
you know going on in the bus whatever
because you know what hey Michael pass
me the ball I had to make the shot and
there were no excuses
BJ Armstrong here on the Rich Eisen show
and obviously we won't talk about
business all business Michael was that
and it may stick out like a sore thumb
here in 2020
where
I guess there's a lot more kumbaya in
some parts of the world what was your
first impression of Michael and when did
you learn boy you better come buttoned
up prepared bring your a-game all the
time
BJ well you know IIIi quickly saw him
you know really transcend you know
something that I had never seen before
you know most players you know I've seen
players you know tap into his own right
you have a good game may have a good
weeks might have a good month but this
guy had a great day every single day and
not only in the games but he was great
in practice and now I knew that I had to
find a way to play and perform at his
level in spite of myself not having a
great game and he demanded that of you
physically mentally emotionally every
single time he hit the floor so there
was no well I had a bad game well okay
he had a bad game but he still was gonna
find a way so he had a he had a
principle that he would always say from
time to time you know the score is
always zero zero because he was such a
he was such an incredible defensive
player that if he wasn't score and you
didn't score he was still in the game
so as great as he was on the offensive
end really he was a blue-collar
defensive grind-it-out type of player
who just happened to be a great
offensive player and as you know rich
you know you've been around um no
defense about effort and energy right
every night you can be a great defensive
player every night you can give that
type of effort so he just gave all of us
who were around him a different way
because he was gonna find a way to win
the game no matter what he was gonna
find a way he was gonna if you needed to
get an offensive rebound if you need to
get it still if he needed to make a
defensive stop he was going to do what
was ever necessary to do that because he
had the skill set but more importantly
he had the mental toughness to focus in
and get the job done and you know people
talk about doing things but he could
actually go out do it and he did it so
you know what we
had to find a way to elevate our games
if you will to maintain and support what
he was doing because he wasn't gonna
stop do you ever get on you
did he ever curse you well of course you
know like one of my fondest memories of
Michael is that Michael was one of the
guys right he loved being one of the
guys and he you know when the Air Jordan
and the cameras were off he felt
comfortable being one of the guys so
trash-talking and being truthful with
one another is part of building a
relationship if you're going to achieve
that level of success but the thing is
Michael also would give it out but the
thing that was most impressive is he
could take it huh he could take it you
couldn't say back to him that's gonna
come out so he he was he was he was
truthful in his conversation but he was
respectful to the community areas right
you know you know when you covered a
team there was a music playing around
there wasn't people disrespecting each
other in the community spaces he was
very respectful but he also wanted to
apply the pressure because he was he was
a person he was a very simple person his
only objective was to win so he didn't
have a hidden agenda he wasn't
interested in well I got to get 35
points I got to win this game and I got
to do whatever is necessary to win this
game so as complicated as it may seem it
was very very simple because he was
going to do what he had to do for one
objective to win and anything else you
know that that's that you didn't know
who he was and as long as you had that
same goal then you had no problems with
that sure but who would give it back to
him and over what you know what i'ma
tell you you know Bill Cartwright was a
terrific veteran he was a terrific
veteran and when things what happened
outside you know when things happened
you know of course Michael was our best
player of course you know he was
he had a huge voice but Bill Cartwright
was the he was the he had he when he did
speak it was too well taken and we see
by everyone in that locker room because
bill was he was a pro's Pro right he was
a pro he was a pro and everything the
way he prepared the way he played what
he was able to do for the team and all
of those things and he had a huge voice
and he was always there if things kind
of got just off the tracks a little bit
bill had away you know of getting us
back on the tracks you know that's why
we always nicknamed him the teacher he
was the teacher he was the one who kept
us in line we were all young bill had
been around people forget bill was a
20-point scorer when in his New York
days mm-hmm and then trance he
transitioned his game to be a defensive
player when he got to Chicago so he did
what he had to do and he was well
respected so we just had great
leadership we had great veteran
leadership we had great leadership on my
star which was Michael Jordan field
Jackson so we had all of the intangible
things that was necessary for us to
compete and win at the highest level and
that's my last question for you BJ
Armstrong
how did Phil make it all work and you
had a front row seat I know you love and
respect that guy I mean you want to talk
about personalities my gosh I mean the
alpha dog of all alpha dogs is Michael
Jordan and then everything else that you
just mentioned Pippen wanting to get
paid all of the how did Phil Jackson
make it all work from your perspective
pill Jackson was very clear in that you
know he was coaching every time he would
give a speech he understood that he was
given 12 different speeches for the
pregame speech bill Jackson understood
the mindset of what it was like to be a
player and I think he learned that from
you know being a player I think there's
something that you understand how to
operate in this dysfunctional
environment right and Phil Jackson the
more chaos
Jackson the better he is he's better
when there's chaos if there's nothing
going on you know you know he's a really
good coach but if there's chaos if
there's something going on if there's
whatever he's that much better so I
think what may feel Jackson connect with
this group is because we were a group
the more drama and chaos was going on
off the court Michael Jordan was that
much better our team was that much
better Phil Jackson functioned that much
better he was so much better of a coach
when we were the chips were when our
backs were against the wall you know
Phil Jackson would he would be so mad
sometimes that he wouldn't even call a
timeout if a teammate a six eight or run
and in a crazy way we respected that
because we're like oh this guy's just as
crazy as we are the connection of
knowing that hey this guy's the same as
because you know he's a little off
center I'm a little off center well you
know what we had something in common and
even though we were all different from
different backgrounds he connects with
the dysfunction of what this league is
you know coaching an NBA team let alone
an NBA superstar that's a very difficult
thing Phil Jackson gets it whatever it
is he gets that and he has a connection
with the players he has a connection
with the team and I can tell you what if
you have a team that was ready to win
you know I couldn't think of a better
coach to get you over the top and Phil
Jackson and he not only did he do that
in Chicago he did that in LA and you
know that was a gift that he had he was
he knew how to function in the chaos and
he was and the more chaotic it was you
know he was better so I think some
people have a talent that was his talent
BJ this has been awesome
I mean knew it would be too and I knew I
knew I'm like let's have a different
guest on every Monday after the last
dance let's get BJ Armstrong on first
and I knew after I talked to you I'd
want nobody else for the rest of the
next you're the best - that's BJ
Armstrong
right here in the Rich Eisen show love
that guy hey you watched all the way to
the end thanks for that watch more right
here